This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. A chair is a difficult object. A skyscraper is almost easier. Those are the words of Mee's Van der Ra, one of many architects who have also designed chairs. Eames, Geary, Adeed, Leviscind, Kubusier, Breuer. If they've designed a big building, chances are they've designed a thing on which to set. And this makes sense that chairs would be signature design pieces for architects, because chairs are almost like teeny tiny buildings for one person. Producer, Avery, Trupplement.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。椅子是一个复杂的物件，摩天大楼反而更容易设计。这是密斯·凡·德·罗的名言，他也是众多设计过椅子的建筑师之一。伊姆斯、盖里、阿德耶、勒·柯布西耶、布劳耶。如果他们设计过大型建筑，那么他们很可能也设计过供人坐的物件。建筑师将椅子视为标志性的设计作品是有道理的，因为椅子就像是为一个人准备的微型建筑。制作人：艾弗里·特鲁普曼。
And of course it's not just architects. Designers of all stripes have this love affair with chairs. Well, I think every designer really would love to design a chair. I mean, there's so many interesting things about chairs. This is designer Bruce Hanna. I'm a teacher at Pratt Institute in Brooklyn, New York, and designed things for all for years. Including plenty of chairs for the office,
当然，不仅仅是建筑师。各行各业的设计师都对椅子有着这种情结。嗯，我想每一位设计师都渴望设计一把椅子。我的意思是，关于椅子有太多有趣的事情了。这是设计师布鲁斯·汉纳。我是纽约布鲁克林普瑞特艺术学院的老师，多年来设计过各种东西。包括很多办公室用的椅子，
for the home, everything. Chairs exist. They kind of are like placeholders for human beings. You know, you go into a restaurant that's empty and there's all these little placeholders, you know. Yet when the people sit in the chair, it disappears. The person replaces the chair. And so there's this distinct challenge for chair designers. To make this thing look fantastic when empty and remain comfortably invisible when in use. And Hannah's pursuit of seating innovation actually led to something else. When he was experimenting with foam cushioning, Hannah accidentally invented the Nerf ball.
还有家用的，应有尽有。椅子是真实存在的。它们就像是人类的占位符。你知道，当你走进一家空荡荡的餐厅，那里摆满了各种小占位符。然而，当人坐进椅子里，椅子就消失了。人取代了椅子。所以，椅子设计师面临着一个独特的挑战：让椅子在空置时看起来美轮美奂，而在使用时又能舒适地隐形。汉纳对座椅创新的追求实际上引向了别的东西。当他在试验泡沫垫时，汉纳意外发明了Nerf球。
Well actually it's called the foam football. Still really cool. It did come out of designing the chair. I mean we're much more interested in the chair. Yes, those designers sure do love chairs. Love them. They keep turning out new ones all the chair. I mean, we're much more interested in the chair. Yes, those designers sure do love chairs. Love them. They keep turning out new ones all the time, which brings me to one of my favorite headlines from the onion. Quote, report confirms no need to make new chairs for the time being. Because yeah, there are already a lot. I think you could say that about anything.
其实它叫泡沫足球。还是很酷的。它确实源于椅子设计。我的意思是，我们对椅子更感兴趣。是的，那些设计师确实很爱椅子。非常爱。他们一直在不断推出新款。我的意思是，我们对椅子更感兴趣。是的，那些设计师确实很爱椅子。非常爱。他们一直在不断推出新款，这让我想起了《洋葱报》我最喜欢的标题之一。引用：报告证实，目前没有必要制造新椅子。因为是的，已经有很多了。我想你可以对任何事物都这么说。
Well, we have enough cars. Let's stop making cars. Personally, I wouldn't be against that, but new chairs are always coming out, Hannah says, to fit our ever-changing needs, because chairs determine how we use a space. Hannah brought up this great example of seating in cafes. Cafes used to be places for talking, and now they're places for working. So people are sitting and interacting differently.
嗯，我们已经有足够的汽车了。别再造车了。就我个人而言，我不反对这一点，但汉纳说，新椅子不断涌现是为了满足我们不断变化的需求，因为椅子决定了我们如何使用空间。汉纳提到了咖啡馆座椅的一个很好的例子。咖啡馆过去是谈话的地方，现在是工作的地方。所以人们坐着和互动的方式也不同了。
And so the furniture evolves along with the space and the activities. Throughout our lives we have been told to sit down in school, in the office, in the plate company of a dinner party, in a car or a plane or a bus or a movie theater sitting is the default. We spend a lot of time in chairs. But I'm sure you heard all the talk lately about how unhealthy chairs are, especially if you listen to public radio, which I bet you do, you beautiful nerd. First we'll talk about chronic sitting. Are you sitting down? Well, you might want to stand up.
因此，家具随着空间和活动而演变。纵观我们的一生，我们被告知要坐下：在学校、办公室、晚宴的礼貌场合、汽车、飞机、公共汽车或电影院里，坐着是默认状态。我们在椅子上花了很多时间。但我敢肯定，你最近听到了很多关于椅子有多不健康的讨论，特别是如果你听公共广播的话，我敢打赌你听了，你这个可爱的书呆子。首先，我们来谈谈长期久坐。你现在坐着吗？嗯，你可能想站起来。
It turns out that sitting down can be bad for your health. And those who were sitting more were substantially more likely to die. Geez. I think I found like five articles with the headline, were sitting more, were substantially more likely to die. Geez. I think I found like five articles with the headline, sitting is the new smoking. The absolute number of hours that you sit is directly correlated with mortality from all causes.
事实证明，久坐可能对健康有害。那些坐得更多的人死亡的可能性要大得多。天哪。我想我找到了大约五篇标题为“久坐是新的吸烟”的文章。你坐的时间总量与各种原因导致的死亡率直接相关。
Cancer, heart attack and stroke. And it doesn't matter how many hours you spend in the gym as compensation. This is Professor Galen Kranz. You come in and the secretary says, have a seat. She doesn't know, she's wishing you death. You know, it's a death wish. Ha ha!
癌症、心脏病和中风。而且无论你在健身房花多少小时来补偿都没用。这是盖伦·克兰茨教授。你走进去，秘书说，请坐。她不知道，她是在祝你早死。你知道，这是一种死亡诅咒。哈哈！
This research, along with those scary headlines, has led to a new market for medicine ball chairs, adjustable chairs, standing desks, treadmill desks. The chair backlash is upon us. And Berkeley architecture professor Gaelin Kranz totally nailed it way before anyone else. Yes, yes, it is nice to that people are, you know, saying that I was prescient and I wasn't prescient.
这项研究，连同那些可怕的标题，催生了一个新的市场：健身球椅、可调节椅子、站立式办公桌、跑步机办公桌。椅子反击战已经打响。伯克利建筑学教授盖伦·克兰茨早在其他人之前就完全预见到了这一点。是的，是的，人们说我有先见之明，这很好，但我并没有什么先见之明。
Everybody else was just blind. In 1998, Kranz published a book called The Chair, rethinking culture, body, and design. And the argument of the chair is that we should stop sitting in chairs. At least we should stop sitting in them for so long. Up to three hours doesn't seem to have much consequence. But Professor Cran's takes innovative chair sitting to another level. I try to eliminate all conventional chairs in my own life.
其他人只是视而不见。1998年，克兰茨出版了一本名为《椅子：重新思考文化、身体与设计》的书。这本书的论点是，我们应该停止坐在椅子上。至少我们应该停止长时间坐在椅子上。坐三个小时以内似乎没什么后果。但克兰茨教授将创新的坐姿提升到了另一个层次。我试图在自己的生活中消除所有传统的椅子。
Which presented a challenge when I went to go interview her? I wonder if let's see how should we sit. Professor Kranz's house was full of floor cushions to Tommy Mats and lots and lots of unconventional hybrid chairs, like a medicine ball on an office chair chassis and one that looked like a sleek, paired-down horse saddle. And when she's not in her home seating oasis and out in public, Professor Cran's does a lot of standing.
这在我去采访她时带来了一个挑战。我想知道，让我们看看我们该怎么坐。克兰茨教授的房子里到处都是地板垫、榻榻米和许多非常规的混合椅子，比如放在办公椅底座上的健身球，还有一把看起来像光滑、精简的马鞍的椅子。当她不在她的家庭座椅绿洲，而是在公共场合时，克兰茨教授经常站着。
And instead of sitting when she gets tired, she opts to kneel or squat or lie down. I laid down in a bank and somebody came up and asked me if I was having a heart attack, which was kind of them. You know, I understand. But I said, no, I'm fine, I'm just resting because the line is so long. You've got to be gutsy to actually avoid the chairs everywhere.
当她累了的时候，她选择跪着、蹲着或躺下，而不是坐着。我在银行躺下，有人走过来问我是不是心脏病发作了，他们很善良。你知道，我理解。但我说，不，我很好，我只是在休息，因为排队太长了。你必须有胆量才能真正避开到处都是的椅子。
So how did the rest of us get suckered into the seated position? Well, it all started when we got off the farm. In the 20th century, we moved from being an agricultural economy where most people worked on forms.. Then we moved into a manufacturing economy where a lot of people worked in factories and some sat, some stood to work the machines on the long-accombaire belts. Not to over romanticize life on the farm. They were still doing back breaking work. They just probably had better posture and less carpal tunnel syndrome. And then we moved into a service economy. And that seems to be where the chair really took off and became the dominant apparatus for our lives.
那么我们其他人是怎么被诱导进入坐姿的呢？嗯，这一切始于我们离开农场的时候。在20世纪，我们从农业经济转向了大多数人在农场工作的经济。然后我们进入了制造业经济，很多人在工厂工作，有些人坐着，有些人站着操作流水线上的机器。并不是要过度美化农场生活。他们仍然在做繁重的体力劳动。他们只是可能有更好的姿势，更少的腕管综合症。然后我们进入了服务经济。这似乎是椅子真正兴起并成为我们生活中主导设备的地方。
And then when we settled into the service economy, sitting became the way to type and file and fill out paperwork. You could do that standing, but for reasons I don't fully understand, we did it sitting. And so office chairs become the chairs, the chairs that people spend most of their day in. And until very recent history, they were not made to fit your body. They were made to fit your job. So you had to manage your real one, you had to middle manage your real one, you had a secretary of one, you had a task chair. Bruce Hanna had to design a few of these kinds of office chairs.
然后当我们进入服务经济时，坐着成了打字、归档和填写文书工作的方式。你可以站着做这些，但出于我不完全理解的原因，我们坐着做了。于是办公椅成了椅子，人们一天中大部分时间都坐在这些椅子上。直到最近，它们也不是为了适应你的身体而制造的。它们是为了适应你的工作而制造的。所以你有你的行政椅，你有你的中层管理椅，你有你的秘书椅，你有你的任务椅。布鲁斯·汉纳不得不设计一些这种类型的办公椅。
The status oriented chair design meant that in some cases. You had the 120 pound executive sitting in a gigantic chair because it really was about his presence when he wasn't there or her presence when he wasn't there. And then you had the 160 pound assistant secretary sitting in this tiny little chair. For the most part, status trumped organomics. And then along comes 1992, the the air on chair, where it's the same chair just comes in three sizes. It's a t-shirt. A small one, medium, one, and a big one. But everybody gets.
这种以地位为导向的椅子设计意味着在某些情况下，你会有120磅重的行政人员坐在巨大的椅子上，因为这确实关乎他的存在感，或者当他不在时她的存在感。然后你会有160磅重的助理秘书坐在这种小椅子上。在大多数情况下，地位胜过了人体工程学。然后到了1992年，Aeron椅子出现了，它是同一把椅子，只是有三种尺寸。它就像一件T恤。小号、中号和大号。但每个人都能得到。
All of the adjustments, they get arms, they get everything they need to work. Because everyone is working equally hard in the office. The Herman Miller Aeron Chair. You've seen an Aeron Chair. It's got this mesh looking back. And you've probably heard it mentioned on public radio. You're beautiful nerd. Support for NPR comes from Sitver Life in Herman Miller, featuring the Aeron Chair,
所有的调节功能，他们有扶手，他们有工作所需的一切。因为每个人在办公室里都同样努力工作。赫尔曼·米勒的Aeron椅子。你见过Aeron椅子。它有这种网状的靠背。你可能在公共广播里听到过它。你这个可爱的书呆子。NPR的支持来自Sitver Life和赫尔曼·米勒，主打Aeron椅子，
including the True Black color. They're usually black, or true black. There's one of them everywhere. I was surprised when I walked into the studio today that you don't have a couple here, you know, because they're everywhere. They're ubiquitous. They're ubiquitous, chair. And the Aeron Chair brought on this age of ergonomic office chairs that look like little robots.
包括纯黑色款。它们通常是黑色的，或者纯黑色的。到处都有它们。今天走进演播室时我很惊讶，你们这里居然没有几把，你知道，因为它们到处都是。它们无处不在。无处不在的椅子。Aeron椅子开启了这个看起来像小机器人的符合人体工程学的办公椅时代。
They display their technology as a selling point, and they show off their swivels and their adjustments and their ergonomic technology. The Aeron Chair defined what an office chair ought to look like. Right now, I think it's what society says that that will make me comfortable. That piece of machinery. And no one guessed that these expensive pieces of machinery would sell like hotcakes.
它们展示自己的技术作为卖点，炫耀它们的旋转、调节和人体工程学技术。Aeron椅子定义了办公椅应该是什么样子。现在，我认为这就是社会所说的能让我舒适的东西。那台机器。而且没人猜到这些昂贵的机器会像热卖品一样畅销。
No one except Gaelin Grants. When my book first came out, people said, well, you know, nobody's going to pay for an ordinary clerk to have an adjustable chair with all the bells and whistles. Oh, that's way too expensive that'll never happen. Well, then there were repetitive strain injury in a whole lot of lawsuits, and insurance companies suddenly thought it was a lot cheaper to buy those fancy adjustable chairs than to pay for medical bills. Crans is a fan of what she calls body conscious design, and considers any chair that takes the human figure into account is a vast improvement over,
除了盖伦·克兰茨，没人猜到。我的书刚出版时，人们说，嗯，你知道，没人会花钱让普通职员坐上一把带有所有花哨功能的调节椅。哦，那太贵了，永远不会发生。好吧，后来出现了重复性劳损，引发了一大堆诉讼，保险公司突然认为购买那些昂贵的可调节椅子比支付医疗费用要便宜得多。克兰茨是她所说的“身体意识设计”的拥护者，认为任何考虑到人体形态的椅子都比……要好得多。
say, a beanbag chair. But Cran's argues that some of those bells and whistles on office chairs actually don't help that much, specifically those ergonomic chairbacks. Because in all likelihood, you are probably sitting in this chair while working at a desk. And the desk, it turns out, is the chair's devious accomplice. The true villain is the table. Flat surfaces force you to lean over, so you never really take advantage of the chair back. The chair in particular asks us to sit at this right angle position, but most of our work
比如懒人沙发。但克兰茨认为，办公椅上的那些花哨功能实际上并没有多大帮助，特别是那些符合人体工程学的椅背。因为很有可能，你坐在椅子上工作时是在桌子前。事实证明，桌子是椅子的狡猾帮凶。真正的恶棍是桌子。平坦的表面迫使你弯腰，所以你从来没有真正利用到椅背。椅子特别要求我们以这种直角姿势坐着，但我们大部分的工作
is forward oriented. Clerical work, reading, writing checks, and eating even, or drinking tea and coffee, and all of everything's forward. So you bend forward, or more likely slump. Even if you have excellent posture, it's hard to avoid leaning over your keyboard or your dinner or your book. So the head gets seduced into coming forward, that when you curve your spine into the C shape, it's bad for the spine, of course, but it also compresses your organs, which is really bad, especially for hours on end throughout the day in an office chair. And because of this
都是面向前方的。文书工作、阅读、写支票、甚至吃饭，或者喝茶喝咖啡，所有的一切都在前方。所以你向前弯腰，或者更可能的是瘫坐。即使你的姿势很好，也很难避免弯腰对着键盘、晚餐或书本。所以头部被诱导向前，当你把脊椎弯成C形时，这当然对脊椎不好，但它也会压迫你的器官，这真的很糟糕，特别是在办公椅上整天坐着的时候。正因为这种
horrible chair desk dynamic, chair designers can't solve much by adding ergonomic elements to the chairbacks. Actually, Professor Kranz thinks we should do away with back support entirely. I think back support is a big mistake and it's weakened our backs. If you support something, you're usually weak in it. So if you're in a situation where you must, must sit in the chair. Kranz says it's best to ignore the chair back and sit yourself right at the edge of your seat. Right out to the edge, that way you don't get seduced to using the chair back. If your own torso strength keeps you upright with this strategy of getting your sit bones out to the edge of the chair,
可怕的椅子与桌子的动态关系，椅子设计师通过在椅背上增加人体工程学元素解决不了多少问题。事实上，克兰茨教授认为我们应该完全取消背部支撑。我认为背部支撑是一个巨大的错误，它削弱了我们的背部。如果你支撑某样东西，你通常就会在那方面变弱。所以如果你处于必须坐在椅子上的情况，克兰茨说最好忽略椅背，坐在座位的边缘。一直坐到边缘，这样你就不会被诱导去使用椅背。如果你的躯干力量能让你保持直立，通过这种让坐骨坐在椅子边缘的策略，
you're turning it into a stool. Stools, Kranz says, are a good alternative to chairs because they don't have back support and they get your body out of the C shape. It positions the body halfway between sitting and standing. And if you take that body position and lean it backwards, what do you get? A lounge chair. And that's how I'm positioned right now. Yeah, Gaelin Cran's was reclining any lounge chair for this interview. I'll be in the lounge, and I'll have you
你实际上把它变成了一把凳子。克兰茨说，凳子是椅子的一个很好的替代品，因为它们没有背部支撑，而且能让你的身体摆脱C形。它将身体定位在坐和站之间。如果你采取那种身体姿势并向后倾斜，你会得到什么？一把躺椅。这就是我现在的位置。是的，盖伦·克兰茨在这次采访中正躺在躺椅上。我会躺在休息室里，我会让你
in the rocking chair facing me. And she put me in a rocking chair, because unlike a normal chair, it allows for more fluidity and movement. And this all sounds great and healthy and fun. But in practice, I was sitting all the way forward, rocking right to the very front, stretching my microphone out to Krance,
坐在面对我的摇椅上。她让我坐在摇椅上，因为与普通椅子不同，它允许更多的流动性和运动。这听起来很棒、很健康、很有趣。但在实践中，我一直坐在最前面，摇到最前端，把麦克风伸向克兰茨，
who was lying back in her lounge chair. And it hurt. I just wanted two chairs and a flat desk to rest my arm on. But I don't know, maybe I just wasn't used to this alternative world yet. Maybe I need to get acclimated, I don't know. I mean, Professor Krance looked pretty comfortable in her lounge chair. Before people got so into standing desks and treadmill desks.
她正躺在她的躺椅上。这很疼。我只想要两把椅子和一张平坦的桌子来支撑我的手臂。但我不知道，也许我还不习惯这个替代世界。也许我需要适应一下，我不知道。我的意思是，克兰茨教授在她的躺椅上看起来很舒服。在人们如此热衷于站立式办公桌和跑步机办公桌之前，
Professor Kranz was sure that lounge chairs and lounge chair desks would replace chair sitting. Of all the solutions to the seating problem, the lounge chair is the solution that requires the least physical effort while still supporting the human body in a healthy way. But it's not like there's one single piece of furniture that will correct all the problems of chair sitting.
克兰茨教授确信躺椅和躺椅办公桌会取代坐姿。在所有解决坐姿问题的方案中，躺椅是物理努力最少，同时又能以健康方式支撑人体的解决方案。但这并不是说有一件单一的家具能纠正坐姿的所有问题。
No, lounge chair is not the answer. There's no the answer. What we need is variety. The best posture is the next posture. Bruce Hanna agrees. The more variation in your day, the better off. But he's not chair avoidant. Sitting is the new smoking? Really? We
不，躺椅不是答案。没有唯一的答案。我们需要的是多样性。最好的姿势是下一个姿势。布鲁斯·汉纳也同意。你一天中的变化越多越好。但他并不排斥椅子。“久坐是新的吸烟”？真的吗？我们
should be up and running every day. Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run. Is that mean that all restaurants will be, will be running in place at restaurants? They'll be treadmills. Right? Will there, nothing be sacred? I like to sit. I want to sit down. And I deal space to live or to work could be full of unconventional mismatched chairs for you to try out and cycle through like in Galen Cranc's dining room. People say, oh, wow, you have a lot of chairs. I say, oh, yeah, it's a chair museum. And I say, oh, try, be sure to try them all. And people do. They like, they say, well, I've said in that one, can I go try that one and have way through the dinner, you know. The middle class thing is you want everything to match. And it's fun that these don't match. Everybody loves it, trying out all the different attitudes towards seating reform.
应该每天跑来跑去。跑，跑，跑，跑，跑，跑，跑，跑。那是不是意味着所有的餐馆都会……在餐馆里原地跑步？会有跑步机。对吧？难道没有什么东西是神圣的吗？我喜欢坐着。我想坐下。一个理想的生活或工作空间应该充满非常规的、不匹配的椅子，让你尝试并循环使用，就像在盖伦·克兰茨的餐厅里一样。人们说，哦，哇，你有很多椅子。我说，哦，是的，这是一个椅子博物馆。我说，哦，一定要都试一试。人们确实会试。他们说，嗯，我坐过那把了，我可以去试那把吗？在晚餐进行到一半时，你知道。中产阶级的东西是你想要一切都配套。这些不配套反而很有趣。每个人都喜欢尝试所有关于座椅改革的不同态度。
But the solution isn't just a like only in Berkeley kind of thing. So maybe in this one case, this one exception, the onion is wrong. We don't need fewer things to sit on. It turns out we need more. And all different kinds, stools, purchase, lounge chairs, and hell, throwing some desk redesigns while you're at it. Ones that rise up to meet us like drafting tables, design more, much, much more, bring me more chairs! All the chairs. 99% Invisible was Produced This Week by
但解决方案不仅仅是那种只在伯克利才有的东西。所以也许在这个案例中，这个唯一的例外，洋葱报是错的。我们不需要更少的椅子。事实证明，我们需要更多。各种各样的，凳子、高脚凳、躺椅，见鬼，顺便把桌子也重新设计一下。那些像绘图桌一样升起来迎接我们的桌子，设计更多，多得多，给我更多的椅子！所有的椅子。本周的《99%隐形》由……制作。
We are a project of 91.7 Local Public Radio, KALW in San Francisco, and produced out of the offices of Arxine in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links, and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible. You must go to 99pi.org. Radio tapio. FAPIORX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目，我们所有人都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解更多关于这个故事的信息，包括很酷的图片和链接，并收听《99%隐形》的所有剧集，你必须访问99pi.org。Radio Tapio。FAPIORX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。